Tinka world a place where everything can  be built from basic materials as long as  the idea behind it is strong enough from  ancient forests to bustling cities or is  crafted with nothing more than color  paper and glue even small pets or giant  ones  paint is reduced in the city of colors  and brings life to the inhabitants of  tinker world everybody has a favorite  shade which makes them individual but  now the city is in danger fortitude has  turned to sadness curiosity to fear and  strength to anger people have divided  the city into districts even starting to  hate other colors only in the outer  district where all colors are accepted  our people still normal but among them  it's a boy with very special talents  soon he will start a chain of events  that will destroy the city  you